Welcome back everyone this be my new Eternals
trailer video.
They just released a new Imax Trailer that's
a little bit different than the last one.
So there's a bunch of Easter eggs.
I figured it's a good opportunity to talk
about the new marvel cosmic hierarchy and
explain the celestials and where everybody
fits in now, because as you see from the Spider-Man
No Way Home Trailer it's getting so crazy
in marvel phase 4.
So if you're brand-new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos the
Eternals movie is coming up next month so
we're going to start seeing a whole bunch
more footage for really soon too.
And I will explain where Kang in the multiverse
war figures into all this.
Like he who remains.
Because obviously on the Loki series we saw
that he been controlling the main MCU timeline.
The sacred timeline from start to finish the
whole time.
So even been watching over the birth of eternity
the celestials the Eternals everything the
played out from the start of the timeline
to the very end of time.
There is still a hierarchy of cosmic beings
in the MCU their way more powerful than anything
we've seen before.
So the Eternals movie is really just the introduction
to some of those cosmic beings is not meant
to be a one and done with the celestial host
their way too powerful for that.
But the movie is also meant to tell the true
origin of the celestials in the actual origin
of the universe the marvel cinematic universe
in a more traditional way than the sacred
timeline.
The king gave us, which represents the main
MCU universe.
We been operating in throughout all the marvel
movies so far.
So when he who remains Kang was telling us
his back story.
He was kind of giving us a backstory in the
universe and during the guardians of the galaxy
movie.
The collector kind of gave us a backstory
on the universe.
But is really only part of the story.
The Eternals movie is going to fill in all
those gaps what he who remains Kang on Loki
started to explain though was the cycle of
big bangs like this is not the first version
of the universe that you're living in it's
a loop.
It operates on a loop universe is born in
the Big Bang eventually dies heat death that
is reborn in a new version of the universe.
So in the MCU.
We don't know which version of the universe
were in we just know that is been through
a couple of cycles already.
But before the Big Bang there was something
it was basically called utter chaos, the void
where the dark elves were born were beings
like Shuma Gorath ruled over chaos lords when
the first big bang happens in the first universe
is born.
It has a consciousness is called eternity
so that universe itself is alive
eventually that universe, winds up dying it's
heat death and contracts again go through
another big bang cycle becoming the second
version of the universe.
The only thing that he who remains Kang did
to mess with this process the cycle of big
bangs the birth and rebirth of the universe
is the only changes things so that everything
will play out the same or close to the same
in every single time loop start to finish
where you get to the multiverse of it all
is that during the second big bank that's
when the multiverse was born.
This is just one version of eternity one consciousness
Fort.
Although, also during the second Big Bang
is when the infinity stones are created when
the collector was explaining then to the guardians
of the galaxy.
He said before the Big Bang there were six
singularities that survive the Big Bang process
and then were forced into ingots actual infinity
stones that story is only half the story.
The six singularities were the remnants of
the former version of the universe.
They represent all the cosmic power of that
entire universe distilled down into six singularities.
So when you're wielding the infinity stones
your wielding the cosmic power of an entire
universe.
That's why you're able to affect things on
a universe widescale when I say galactus was
also created the same way the infinity stones
were created.
He started out as a scientist named Galen
who just survive the heat death of his own
universe in the next big bank and during that
Big Bang process he was imbued with immense
cosmic energy changing him into galactus galactus
is similar to the celestials in some ways.
But the reason eternity created him was to
destroy dying worlds so that new life could
grow inside the cosmos.
Like when farmers do controlled burns on their
fields to help enrich the soil.
But on a cosmic scale.
Just like the celestials galactus is really
good or evil.
Only the world's he consumes think of him
as a villain.
But he serves a very important cosmic purpose,
but also starting in the second Big Bang and
then future big bangs that would eventually
happen in each of the different universes
fraternity winds up creating the first celestial
host the ones that we see walking around in
all the marvel trailers in the MCU they're
led by aeration the judge this giant red celestial
who they're calling the prime celestial all
the celestials have kind of funny names that
describe what they do the first celestial
host was aeration the judge obviously is in
the name he judges things.
Jeremiah the calculator whose also know where
the head of the dead celestial in present
day all explained that in a second to because
you can kill celestials.
But it's really really hard business are the
calculator hearken the measurer east on the
searcher who we also saw during the guardians
of the galaxy movie and then also ego the
living planet, because he was a celestial
inside the MCU.
But he's kind of like a rogue celestial so
even though eternity gives birth to these
new celestials and tells them to go out in
garden experiment with life in the universe.
If you're fan of the berserk manga theyr'e
kind of like the God Hand, they're not good
they're not evil.
Just go out and do as thou wouldst.
To try experimenting with things.
Ego the living planet is different because
he's a rogue celestial so even though it might
seem like eternity is telling the celestials
what to do.
It's actually not quite like that.
It just creates them and then just let's them
go out and do whatever it is that they feel
like doing.
Imagine the world's worst absentee parent,
so ego the living planet doesn't feel like
being part of the celestial host they don't
force him to be part of the celestial host
when eternity creates the celestials it imbues
them with immense cosmic power and just to
give you an idea for how much cosmic power
they wield.
You could probably slow one down temporarily.
Just for like a hot second with one infinity
stone, but you need the entire infinity gauntlet
to actually have a chance at stopping one.
They use vibranium to form a lot of their
actual bodies like the physical bodies that
they walk around in.
So a lot of people theorize that the vibranium
mound in wakanda was actually sent to planet
Earth or they orchestrated things the celestials
did that that vibranium would be used in the
creation of the brand-new celestial this growing
in planet Earth the best sense for scale that
I could give you would be some of these comic
book panels here with and just towering over
everything.
So really only beings like Galactus have a
chance of action fighting celestials without
a huge power up if your big comic book fan
iron man actually wore the God killer armor
that was actually an Iron Man suit that was
essentially a celestial Iron Man suit created
by some dark versions of the celestials call
the aspirants there can be doing that in the
movies anytime soon.
But it was a really cool comic book twist
the size of the celestial host fluctuates
over time.
Like I said you can kill celestials like you
did see Knowhere the head of the dead celestial
during guardians of the galaxy in present
day and they can actually reproduce so to
speak kind of they can create more celestials.
But it takes millions and millions of years
and massive amounts of cosmic energy the you
just don't find in present day.
So that's what you don't see thousands of
celestials flying around in space, but because
there are millions of worlds in the universe
for them to experiment on in is only a couple
celestials they create lesser beings to basically
delegate a lot of the management to in the
MCU that I she starts with the deviants the
sea like Kro here.
He's one of the antagonist of the film you
see him with Angelina Jolie Thena character.
So celestial host sends the celestial egg
to planet Earth to slowly hatched over millions
of years, but is meant to slowly absorb enough
cosmic energy in order to mature in order
for that to happen.
There needs to be life on planet Earth and
at some point in history the deviants are
going around going rogue ignoring the celestials
orders killing off humans everywhere hurting
the chances that this new celestial will be
born.
So then the celestials create the internals
to go kill the deviants then take their place
shepherding the maturation process of the
celestial egg.
So this is clever trick that they pull with
the trailer footage.
They make it seem like the internals believe
that they were sent to planet Earth to shepherd
over humanity and watch them grow.
Like they fall in love with humanity just
in general when really the celestials don't
care about humans at all their just of food
source like a cosmic food source for this
new celestial that they're trying to grow.
So there is a big change in the way the terminals
are created in the MCU than the comics in
the MCU.
They basically create them with celestial
technology to look humanoid but are kind of
like living celestial robots, which is part
of the reason why they're immortal eternal
functionally the like better celestial versions
of vision.
So they're also kind of soft program.
Like wetware programmed to obey the celestials
commands, which is why Sersi is explaining
to Dane Whitman's black knight character kit
harington's character.
Why they didn't help out by thanos during
avengers infinity war avengers endgame.
The main reason is they were kind of programmed
to not pay attention to things unless the
deviants were threatening the celestials true
goal of incubating this brand-new celestial
that's the emergence that they're talking
about.
Like I said the celestials can create new
celestials and that's with their secretly
using earth for.
I think the trailer does a pretty decent job
of giving an idea for the power scaling of
the internals in the MCU they're about as
powerful as someone like the whole earth,
Thor, or even Captain marvel.
That's about as powerful as they are in the
comics.
Like the not crazy God level powerful like
they couldn't attack a celestial by themselves
in the kind of program to not be able to attack
the celestials over those of you wondering
like a big response Thor.
Who would win in that fight it be pretty even
match most of the terminals names are actually
named after mystical or biblical figures.
Because all these religious stories that you
read about these great deeds the people performed
in ancient history their secretly talking
about things that the internals walked around
doing using their powers.
So really the actual main villains of the
film are the celestials themselves even though
they themselves are really good or evil in
the cosmic sense of things, but just in terms
of power levels.
He remains Kang could've used his quantum
energy and control of time to fight the celestials
if he wanted to the part of the idea the Eternals
movie is that a lot of these characters will
come back in future films obviously will be
sequels to the internals movie as well.
Like internals to eternal three was looking
into more the back story of the MCU and hopefully
see the birth of thanos it would be cool to
see him being born in one of the sequels.
Because he is an eternal just like them.
It is the group of internals that he comes
from came from the planet Titan.
But if you have any big questions about the
celestials or how the origin of the MCU works
of these cosmic beings like eternity just
right them below in the comments and I'll
add than the my future videos my full marvel
what if episode eight video will post Wednesday
just like normal they're having their own
version of a giant multiverse crossover.
Everyone click here for my internals video
about kit harington's black knight character
and click here to learn all about that brand-new
Spider-Man no way home lawsuit that's happening.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you in the next video!